We are the first
The first to see the gods
The first to tame their beasts
The first to guard the soul from evil
We conquered
This land
And built
An empire
But there are whispers on the wind
A Brotherhood
Born in the shadows
They are the first to call themselves
The Assassins
Pre-order now and get a bonus mission.
Secret of the first Pyramids
Ah, Siwa, my home
A sacred oasis
This temple resembles a fortress
What has happened?
Get out of my way
There you are
Medunamun
The next masked one on my list
Now it is my turn
To tip the balance of Anubis
Our people understand
Better be careful here
Ah, a fine bow
Ah, it is too dangerous
I will pass for now